[Musique]
on peut vous parler m'a dit rien il a
dérapé c'est ça toi tu me poussait
encore je te pète la nuque
bienvenue dans bus départ et mckenna
nebraska williams lui et ses collègues
puissent et lynch 12 mercenaires toi
pourquoi tu es là tu es tu veux pas me
croire
aller à lens pec j'ai eu une prise de
tête avec un alien alors lui c'est un
peu plus rien
[Rires]
c'est du coup ça
c'est la chose qui a tué mes hommes
[Applaudissements]
la lienne
et de fait
les prédateurs les exploitent les
faiblesses ratent leurs proies comme un
jeu ils ont l'air d'adorer ça
chasseurs sportifs plus que prédateur on
a tous voté prédateur c'est plus cool
non vous avez un plan
un ex nay peur traumatisée et une bande
d'allumés vous êtes dingues en fait
messieurs ils sont grands qui sont
rapides et monique sc l'arrivée du
tourisme
au fait je pensais je crois qu'on va
creuser
juste pour dire c'est tout
notre malabar est un chasseur il a amené
ses chiens
[Musique]